bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre dans un
instant les débats dessinateur autour du
projet de loi sur la liberté de création
un texte qui était défendu jusqu'à hier
encore par l'ancien ministre de la
culture fleur pellerin mais depuis le
remaniement est passée par là et c'est
donc l'occasion d'entendre pour la
première fois dans l'hémicycle la
nouvelle ministre de la culture
audrey azoulay audrey azoulay qui est
d'ailleurs issus de la même promotion à
l'ena que fleur pellerin et qui était
jusqu'ici conseillère culture et
communication à l'elysée auprès de
françois hollande
le projet de loi du gouvernement vise à
garantir la liberté de création
il vise également à moderniser la
protection du patrimoine
d'ailleurs parmi ces mesures phares noté
qu'il y avait la création de labels du
site est historique
un label qui doit remplacer les
périmètres de protection existants qui
sont multiples mais voilà cette
simplification et est jugée moins
protectrice par de nombreux défenseurs
du patrimoine notamment des élus locaux
les sénateurs nous ont entendus ont
largement modifié le texte en commission
tout de suite donc retour au débat dans
l'hémicycle et sénateurs ont encore plus
de 300 amendements à examiner
ils reprennent les discussions cette
fois ci sur le spectacle vivant et
notamment sur la question de l'assurance
chômage des intermittents du spectacle
la séance est ouverte avant toute chose
je voudrais madame la ministre vous
souhaiter la bienvenue dans cet
hémicycle et formé des voeux pour la
réussite de votre action dans les
nouvelles responsabilités qui vous ont
été confiées
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
président de me donner la parole cela me
permet au nom des membres de la
commission de la culture de la
communication et d'éducation
madame la ministre cheikh audrey azoulay
vous adresser nos salutations
républicaines pour votre nomination vous
dire aussi la bienvenue au sénat pour la
reprise de nos travaux sur la loi
création & architecture patrimoine
pour tout vous dire nous avons effectué
un très gros travail sur ce texte un
texte
maintes fois annoncée maintes fois
différé enfin inscrit et je dois dire
que hier nous avons été quelque peu
désorientés face aux changements de 2 à
la tête du ministère de la culture et de
la communication mais sachez que nous
sommes dans un état d'esprit constructif
au sénat c'est notre tradition que de
vouloir bien faire la loi et donc nous
sommes engagés positivement dans la
poursuite de de ces travaux certains
d'entre nous ont la chance de vous
connaître et savons que nous allons
pouvoir travailler de manière
constructive et fructueuse en tout cas
soyez la bienvenue au nom encore une
fois de l'ensemble des membres de la
commission
merci madame la ministre vous voulez
vous exprimer je vous en prie vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président
pardon je voudrais je voudrais moi aussi
si vous me le permettez dire quelques
mots pour produire d'avoir l'émotion qui
est la mienne d'être dans cette haute
assemblée
aujourd'hui je mesure la responsabilité
qui est la mienne l'émotion aussi d'être
parmi vous je voudrais s'élever parmi
vous des sénateurs que je connais bien
que j'apprécie et avec lesquels je me
réjouis de de travail et je sais qu'un
travail important a déjà été fait en
commission sur ce texte qui a d'ailleurs
amène le gouvernement à faire évoluer
ses positions et je m'en réjouis parce
que je sais qu'ici c'est un travail
constructif qui peut être menée j'ai
eues dans d'autres fonctions
l'occasion aussi de le constater avec
beaucoup de bonheur le ministre donc je
vous donne une indication quant même
pour la journée d'aujourd'hui nous
siégerons jusqu'à ce soir 20h et
l'assurance sera levé à 20h avec une
incertitude sur le rythme de poursuites
nos travaux lors de la semaine prochaine
il faudra très probablement qu'une
conférence des présidents soient réunis
dans la journée d'une marty voilà alors
écoutez nous allons commencer le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué y at il des
observations je n'en vois pas il est
donc adoptée sur les réserves du sage
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relatif à la
liberté de la création à l'architecturé
au patrimoine dans la discussion du
texte de la commission ne sommes
parvenus à l'amendement numéro 2 149
rectifié tendant à insérer un article
additionnel après l'article 13 quater
donc le 409 le 249e rectifié pardon qui
le présente madame gauthier - vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président à mon tour
je voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue à
madame la ministre et j'espère que nous
conduirons dans cet hémicycle ensemble
de fructueux truc yeux travaux en faveur
de la culture et des arts je veux aussi
adresser mes amitiés à madame fleur
pellerin que nous n'avons pas eu
l'occasion de dire salut voila
alors madame et miss mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise une nouvelle fois
défendre la diversité culturelle
partant d'un constat relativement simple
la concentration d'activités à la fois
identique est liée entre quelques mains
conduit bien souvent à une
uniformisation des contenus et donc à
une mise à mal de la diversité
culturelle
notre position vous savez et constante
sur cette question c'est celle que nous
avions eue dans le domaine de la presse
et nous conduire une condition
évidemment la même réflexion
aujourd'hui donc cet amendement vise à
limiter le cumul d'activités par
quelques personnes qui bien souvent se
disent qu'en comptant l'or à la fois la
création la conception la distribution
et la promotion ils pourront la façonner
n'est ce pas là au fond la définition
même de la concentration culturelles et
artistiques
l'enjeu de cet amendement n'est pas
d'empêcher les sociétés commerciales de
pratiquer une activité ou par ailleurs
ils ont des comptes
elles ont des compétences reconnues il
est plutôt question de limiter le cumul
d'activités phénomènes nuisibles à la
diversité culturelle comme je viens de
dire
l'amendement prévoit d'empêcher les
sociétés commerciales lorsque leur
chiffre d'affaires dépasse un seuil fixé
par voie réglementaire de cumuler plus
de deux activités par nier les suivantes
l'exploitation de lieux de spectacle la
production et la diffusion du spectacle
la distribution de billets de spectacles
et l'édition de production ou de
distribution photographique
à titre d'exemple il nous apparaît
aujourd'hui dangereux qu'une même
personne puisse à la fois produire un
spectacle gérer sa promotion ou encore
louer la salle dans laquelle il se joue
et ce pour une raison très simple
comment s'assurer que cette personne
n'utilisera pas pour ces seuls
spectacles une salle parfois public mais
qui serait sous gestion privée voilà
donc je crois que vous aurez saisi
l'intention qu'il est notre travers de
cet amendement merci madame moitié ben
kay l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre je m'associe bien entendu aux
propos de la présidente de la commission
de la culture pour souhaiter la
bienvenue
non seulement vous arrivez au milieu
d'un texte mais vous arrivez également
entre deux amendements l'un qui étaient
débattus hier est un qui va se débattre
aujourd'hui qui va dans le même sujet
donc c'est un peu compliqué cet
amendement qui vient d'être présenté
vise comme celui d'hier a recadré les
concentrations excessives dans le
domaine du spectacle vivant
nous avons développé hier des arguments
qui tendent et a donné un avis
défavorable en l'état en tous cas même
si on compte
l'objectif qui est visé pour éviter ces
concentrations excessives
nous avons développé les arguments du
fait que les contrôles de concentration
sont concerne de très grosses opérations
la législation actuelle comporte déjà
des outils de contrôle et de régulation
en l'état de la situation nous avions
demandé de rejeter cet amendement
c'est donc un avis défavorable merci
madame la ministre pour l'avis du
gouvernement merci je comprends la
préoccupation qui est exprimé sur la
possible concentration pour les salles
dans le spectacle vivant parce que ce
qu'on vise derrière bien sûr c'est à
préserver la diversité artistique qui
s'exprime dans ses salles mais comme l'a
dit le rapporteur aujourd'hui en l'état
de nos connaissances compte tenu des
dispositions de droit commun qui existe
déjà
je vous propose de retirer cet
amendement ou à défaut nous et mettrions
un avis défavorable
d'autant qu'il ya une étude en cours je
crois que ça a dû être mentionné déjà
hier lorsque le thème a déjà été évoqué
une étude en cours au ministère de la
culture pour permettre de mieux préciser
les choses donc défavorable
merci de m wauquiez morin écoutez je
crois que on a eu à plusieurs reprises
l'occasion de porter cette préoccupation
écoutez madame la ministre ça sera un
cadeau de bienvenue je le retire
et il est retiré alors nous poursuivons
avec l'amendement 109 rectifier à
l'article 14 à monsieur assouline
c'est madame robert monsieur le
président un pardon madame robert est
risible bien bienvenue madame la
ministre pour continuer à examiner ce
texte cet amendement vise à réintégrer
le dispositif supprimée lors de l'examen
en commission par notre rapporteur qui
nous le savons n'aime pas beaucoup les
rapports cependant il s'agit d'un
amendement important puisqu'il sait il
prévoit le rendu d'un rapport essentiel
celui sur la situation du dialogue
social et la représentativité des gars
négociateurs professionnels du spectacle
du secteur du spectacle vivant est
enregistrée on connaît les difficultés
des employés du secteur et
et nombre d'entre eux subissent les
affres du régime de l'intermittence
on sait également qu'un certain nombre
de menaces permanentes pèse sur les
annexes 8 et 10 de la convention unedic
le secteur est le seul qui ne soit pas
représentée au niveau
multiprofessionnelle bien que la fais ac
qui regroupe nous le savons plus de 30
organisations disposent pleinement des
compétences pour négocier à ce niveau
j'y reviendrai d'ailleurs dans un
amendement pour soutenir le quatrième
champs multiples professionnels donc je
pense qu'il était importante que nous
parlions de cet article prévoit un
rapport d'expertisé j'espère monsieur le
rapporteur que sur ce rapport qui nous
donnera des éléments pour continuer à
analyser le spectacle vivant vous serez
beaucoup plus des ligier merci see alors
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président oui ben vous
avez ma réponse dans votre commentaire
comme vous le savez notre commission a
supprimé cet article comme il a supprimé
les me demandes de rapports qui sont
présents dans leur texte
et comme il a également donné un avis
défavorable en cours d'examen au
nombreux rapports qui ont encore été
demandée nous pensons ici dans cette
dans notre assemblée nous nous avons
toujours en tout cas depuis quelques
temps et c'est d'éviter dans la loi les
éléments qui ceux qui n'ont pas de
caractère normatif en réalité donc c'est
la raison pour laquelle sur la forme je
suis défavorable sur le fond maintenant
parce que c'est comme le fond qui vous
amène à demander cela sur le fond la
rédaction d'un rapport sur le sujet ne
me paraît pas constituer une réponse
suffisante au regard du problème soulevé
par la représentativité des négociants
de négociateurs professionnels dans le
domaine du spectacle vivant
compte tenu de l'imminence de
l'ouverture de négociations sur la
nouvelle convention d'assurance chômage
qui devrait démarrer bientôt mieux
vaudrait détermine directement les
parties qui seront autorisés à prendre
place autour de la table de négociations
par le biais d'un décret par exemple
comme l'avait proposé notre commission
des affaires sociales lors de l'examen
du projet de loi relatif au dialogue
social et à l'emploi au printemps
dernier
et pour ces deux raisons la première de
forme la deuxième de fonds j'émets un
avis défavorable à cet amendement merci
madame la ministre
merci madame la madame la sénatrice
monsieur le rapporteur
nous sommes favorable à cet amendement
je crois qu'il s'inscrit dans une
dynamique que vous avez rappelé où les
partenaires sociaux se sont vus confier
dans le domaine du spectacle des
responsabilités nouvelles notamment dans
le cadre de la discussion sur le régime
de l'assurance chômage
donc il est important et je crois que
c'est très attendue par les partenaires
sociaux que cette étude puisse être
faite donc position favorable à cet
amendement
merci alors je vais le mettre aux voix
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission est favorable du gouvernement
qui et pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté et l'article 14 arrêts
rétablis nous passons à des additionnels
avec un abonnement centre est rectifié
qui le présente le centre est rectifié
qui présente le centre est rectifié
monsieur assouline
oui à mon tour madame audrey azoulay je
voulais vous vous souhaiter bonne chance
bon travail et et que nous puissions
travailler le mieux sur cette loi qui
est importante
salué le travail fourni par fleur
pellerin et puis vous dire que ce
connais je sais à quel point vous êtes
une femme de culture compétentes et et
ceux qui aiment la culture donc ça c'est
très important pour nous quand on
travaille là dessus parce que c'est
regarder souvent comme un supplément
d'âme et je les dis dans mon
intervention de séance je pense
qu'aujourd'hui plus que jamais c'est
notre âme et il faut les ministres qui
aiment la culture
7 cet amendement était portée beaucoup
plus comme un appel un appel à des
précisions par rapport à des pratiques
qui ont qu'un kg est les intermittents
du spectacle parce que peut-être des
foyers des abus parce que la loi prévoit
des choses qui encadrent mais elle n'est
pas suffisamment précise parfois je sais
que c'est quelque chose qui était portée
par notre collègue maryvonne blondin de
façon importante elle ne peut pas
malheureusement être aujourd'hui en
séance
donc je l'ait maintenue dans un premier
temps pour entendre la ministre et pour
que ce sujet soit portée mais je le dis
aussi si la rédaction et si les réponses
du gouvernement sont satisfaisantes je
le retire est bien entendu merci
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président donc il
s'agit d'interdire le portage salarial
dans les domaines du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel et du spectacle
je rappellerai qu'une ordonnance du 2
avril 2015 est venu encadrer strictement
l'activité
reportage dans les modalités de recours
au portage salarial
une entreprise ne pourrait faire appel à
un salarié porté que pour je cite
l'exécution d'une tâche occasionnelle ne
relevant pas de son activité normale et
permanente ou pour une prestation
ponctuelles nécessitant une expertise
dont elle ne dispose pas c'est déjà une
formulation qui est assez clair dans les
textes
par ailleurs les entreprises de portage
ne peuvent faire que du portage
strictement et elles sont seules à
pouvoir en faire
par conséquent il nous semble qu'un
législation empêche que des entreprises
du spectacle vivant puisse faire
elle-même du portage une mission commune
au ministère de la culture et des
affaires sociales est chargé d'examiner
en ce moment le dispositif de la licence
d'entrepreneur de spectacle vivant et la
question du portage salarial fait partie
de la lettre de mission actuelle
donc je pense qu'il faut lui laisser le
temps aux chers collègues de rendre ses
conclusions pour ces raisons et en
l'état de la situation de ce sujet qui
est en cours d'évolution la commission
vous demande soit de retirer comme vous
l'avez proposer votre amendement soit le
mettrais un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre merci en
réalité même position que le que le rap
commission rapporteur puisque donc
depuis cette ordonnance de 2015 je crois
qu'il y a les moyens juridiques
effectivement 2
de parer à ce risque qui est que je
comprends fort bien que vous évoquez que
vous pointiez et puis il ya la mire la
mission en cours et le travail qui est
réalisé en ce moment je crois qui
permettra de qui permettra aussi de
répondre à votre préoccupation légitime
donc position défavorable si
l'amendement était maintenu merci alors
est il maintenu monsieur assouline
il est retiré il est retiré nous passons
aux 110 rectifié badham robert merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est un amendement important puisqu'il
prévoit la création d'un quatrième
champs multiples professionnels du
spectacle
il est important à plusieurs titres le
chant du spectacle est un niveau de
négociation hybride aujourd'hui car le
législateur ne connaître que trois
niveaux de représentativité la branche
professionnelle au niveau multi
professionnelle et le niveau
interprofessionnel le secteur de la
culture est le seul des secteurs
professionnels à demeurer hors champ il
n'est représentée ni dans le champ
multiprofessionnelle ni dans le champ
interprofessionnel
cette proposition permet donc de régler
la question de la représentativité
patronale au niveau du chant du
spectacle en lui conférant bien sûr un
niveau de représentativité déjà existant
mais juridiquement non sécurisée
aujourd'hui il ne revient il ne remet
bien sûr pas en cause le principe de
délégation des négociations des annexes
8 et 10
au contraire elle vient la compléter en
rendant la consultation obligatoire en
cas d'échec des négociations du secteur
je rappelle que l'organisme qui
représente les employeurs du spectacle
vivant la fesa qui gère les questions
sociales communes aux neuf branches du
secteur du spectacle et est négocié les
accords est compétent sur la question de
l'assurance chômage mais aussi mais
aussi sur l'ensemble des autres
questions sociales
je pense bien sûr à la sécurisation des
parcours professionnels à la médecine du
travail à la pénibilité etc
à ce jour il est hors champ et les
organismes représentatifs du secteur
n'ont jamais pu est associé à la
préparation des accords nationaux
interprofessionnels qui sont transposés
en l'état dans la loi donc les
conséquences peuvent être lourdes et à
ce titre compte tenu des spécificités
d'emplois dans le spectacle il paraît
vraiment essentiel que le secteur soit
consultée par les organismes
interprofessionnels comme le sont les
autres secteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire je pense à l'agriculture bien
sûr en plus mais aussi les professions
libérales
constituent les autres les trois autres
champs la création de ce quatrième chant
permettra donc aux organisations du
secteur d'être associé aux discussions
sur la question du financement du
paritarisme
mais aussi sur le niveau de financement
que pourra obtenir le secteur pour
chacune des branches du spectacle ainsi
pour ne pas mettre en péril vous
imaginez les équilibres par te financier
pardon des partenaires sociaux
l'adoption de notre amendement octroyant
une reconnaissance légale à ce chant
multiprofessionnelle permettrait
véritablement d'asseoir les modalités
d'association des partenaires sociaux
représentatifs de l'ensemble du
spectacle
d'une part pour la négociation des
règles d'assurance chômage mais aussi
pour les questions d'ordre social c'est
un quatrième choc est très attendu par
les professionnels et j'espère que le
rapporteur et la mini seront favorables
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur alors
êtes vous favorable même si le seul
président sa collègue à plusieurs
reprises pendant les auditions depuis le
mois de novembre
et puis en commission nous nous sommes
posé la question de savoir si toutes les
demandes qui était formulée auprès de
nous sur l'aspect social des relations
syndicales étaient vraiment adapté à ce
texte dont je rappelle qu'il a pour
titre liberté de la création
architecture et patrimoine et ceci
d'autant plus que une loi sur le
dialogue social était largement débattue
et que c'eut été probablement le texte
le plus adapté pour régler ces problèmes
ces sujets qui par ailleurs sont
parfaitement légitimes et les sujets
sont infinies donc en l'état
vous demandez c'était cet amendement a
déjà été rejetée en commission vous
revenez avec le même ce que je comprends
connaissant votre opiniâtreté et votre
souci d'aboutir ce que je respecte
également profondément cette question
relève principalement du sens de la
commission des affaires sociales que
nous avons d'ailleurs consulté à ce
sujet
ce mécanisme ayant été créé par la loi
de mars 2014 relative à la formation
professionnelle à l'emploi et la
démocratie sociale
le sénat a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer contre cette proposition en
cours de l'examen de la loi sur le
dialogue social et l'emploi elle avait
reçu deux avis d
arables à la fois de la commission des
affaires sociales et du gouvernement au
moment de la loi de 2014 on ne peut pas
parler de multi professionnels pour le
spectacle vivant est enregistré comme on
le fait pour les activités agricoles les
professions libérales ou l'économie
sociale et solidaire ne relevant pas du
champ couvert par des autres
organisations professionnelles
d'employeurs représentatifs au niveau
national et interprofessionnel c'est à
dire la fnsea unapl et lui laisse donc
avec ces éléments sans remettre en cause
le fond de vos objectifs
je donnerai l'avis défavorable des
madame la ministre
alors notre position est défavorable la
pression du gouvernement est défavorable
à vous citiez la position de la
commission des affaires sociales qu'ils
avaient été je dois dire que les
affaires sociales au niveau du
gouvernement le sont aussi mais je
comprends votre préoccupation simplement
dans l'aujourd'hui dans le mécanisme qui
a été instauré pour notamment la
négociation sur l'assurance chômage on a
déjà un mécanisme d'articulation entre
le niveau professionnel
interprofessionnel qui qui est prévu
donc ça c'est à une première réponse et
puis on a aussi ce rapport que vous
venez de rétablir dans le texte qui va
nous permettre je crois de faire un état
des difficultés d avance d avancée
potentielle sur la représentativité dans
le secteur du spectacle
merci l'amendement est maintenue madame
robert il est donc je le mets aux voix
avec deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre il est adopté
alors nous passons à deux amendements en
discussion commune le 53 rectifié terre
n'est pas soutenue et nous en sommes aux
112 rectifié qui le présente monsieur
assouline l'article l
4622 6 du code du travail soulève des
difficultés d'ordre pratique il dispose
que les dépenses afférentes aux services
de santé au travail sont à la charge des
employeurs dans le cas de services
communs à plusieurs entreprises ces
frais sont répartis proportionnellement
au nombre des salariés était la citation
beaucoup d'entreprises emploient des
artistes et techniciens du spectacle des
journalistes rémunérés à la pige et des
bennes qu'un les personnes qui emploient
ce type de personnel sont par définition
multi employeurs sur la base des
dispositions du code du travail chaque
employeur devrait verser une cotisation
pour chaque contrat d'engagement alors
qu' une seule visite médicale serait
effectué cette situation remettre en
cause tous les efforts entrepris depuis
des décennies pour favoriser la
surveillance médicale de population et
notamment de ces populations qui peuvent
être fragilisés en août la
proportionnalité des frais d'assises sur
l'effectif sans peu en adéquation avec
les missions des services de santé au
travail tel que consacré par la réforme
de 2011 qui lui a qui leur a octroyé un
caractère de plus en plus collectif nous
proposons donc le définir une assiette
centré sur la masse salariale qui
permettrait de prendre en considération
les spécificités des personnels visés
cette solution répondrait à une logique
économique plus clair et plus pertinente
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président bon c'est un
amendement le précédent et n'a pas été
défendu mais c'est le même il consiste
donc à rendre la cotisation des maladies
des employeurs proportionnellement aux
différentes rémunération des différents
employeurs y lisent donc ces deux
amendements à ce que le coût d'adhésion
la médecine du travail des employeurs
d'intermittents de journalistes pigistes
de mannequin ne soit pas calculé sur la
base du nombre de personnes employées au
cours d'une année mais
proportionnellement à la masse salariale
c'est-à-dire au prorata des différents
employeurs cette question relève un de
recense essentiellement du champ de la
commission des affaires sociales
je voudrais cependant donné quelques
éléments déjà on peut s'étonner que
cette questions surgissent soudainement
dans ce texte
alors que la rédaction de l'article elle
l'a 46 22 6 du code du travail est déjà
ancienne elle date de 2007
ensuite deuxième point la réforme de la
médecine du travail est aujourd'hui à
l'étude rapport a été rendu au
gouvernement le 21 mai dernier et cette
question devrait être abordée dans le
projet de loi que la ministre du travail
présentera au mars en mars prochain
tel que c'est prévu dans le calendrier
est donc ce type de disposition il
trouverait davantage sa place
enfin l'adoption de cet amendement
ouvrant la voie à des revendications
multiples pourquoi ne pas également
prévoir des dispositions similaires dans
le secteur du nettoyage ou la grande
majorité des emplois sont à temps
partiel
j'ajouterai un argument qui n'est pas là
c'est que on risque aussi de faire en
sorte que certains nombre
d'intermittents ayant plusieurs ampleur
échappe au fond pour des problèmes
d'organisation à la visite médicale
obligatoire
les employeurs pouvant penser que c'est
l'autre qui s'en occupe et donc il y a
oui tandis que là ils sont quand même
responsable de la veille sur son sur
leur soleil voilà donc pour toutes ces
raisons c'est un avis défavorable à cet
amendement
merci madame la ministre
le sénateur monsieur le rapporteur avis
favorable puisque ce que vous proposez
en fait va remédier a aujourd'hui un
dispositif qui est inadapté aux pigistes
ou mannequins aux intermittents qui ont
effectivement une multiplicité
d'employeurs est donc un régime
le régime perd capita n'est pas n'est
pas adapté donc favorable à cet
amendement
eh bien je levais je vois avec un avis
défavorable de la commission est
favorable du gouvernement qui et pour
qui est contraint qui s'abstient il est
l'adopter le suivant le 37 rectifié
quater n'est pas soutenue nous en sommes
aux 171 rectifié madame robert vous avez
la parole
oui merci monsieur le président alors
cet amendement vise à élargir la
définition des métiers d'art en effet
celle-ci ne concerne aujourd'hui que les
personnes physiques ou les dirigeants de
personnes morales qui exercent une
activité indépendante de production
j'ai bien dit indépendante de création
de transformation de conservation de
restauration du patrimoine
il s'agit d'y intégrer également les
nombreux salariés qui oeuvrent dans les
ateliers manufacture aux entreprises de
notre territoire et qui contribuent tout
autant au rayonnement et à la
transmission des métiers d'art je pense
que nous sommes très attachés à tous ces
métiers qui maillent notre territoire
le fait d'enlever le mot indépendant
permettrait d'élargir cette notion de
métiers d'art merci merci à madame
robert monsieur le rapporteur
sa collègue ce président la définition
des métiers d'art mais a été effective
elle existe elle mérite une réflexion ça
c'est sûr
comme vous le savez nous ne sommes pas
favorables à la multiplicité des
rapports hier nous avons assisté un
rapport sur la situation des archives
visuelles
je suis trompé nous en sommes aux 171
rectifier et là apparemment vous en êtes
au 111 en avance donc sur la discussion
excusez-moi l'allumage au démarrage qui
ne peut compliquer ce matin
donc voilà la qualité d'artisan arrive
ici ça pardon est intrinsèquement liée à
l'accomplissement d'un travail
indépendant oui c'est les métiers d'art
c'est ça c'est bien ça c'est bien ce que
j'avais entendu quand même c'est un
sujet la définition des métiers d'art
pour l'instant la définition ne salent
ne s'adapte cas des personnes
indépendantes ou à des entreprises mais
pas à des salariés le gros sujet qui est
d'ailleurs introduit par un grand nombre
de partenaires aujourd'hui dans ce texte
c'est de vouloir faire reconnaître parmi
l'élite il a là les salariés des
entreprises
alors moi perso ça personnellement je
crois comme nous tous ici sur c'est bon
on a bien observé que dans les sachets
les salariés des entreprises facturière
de maroquinerie de bijouterie il y a là
des mains d'or des vrais artistes
banksy qui ce qui suscite l'admiration
de tout le monde on a tous observé ça et
on est sensible à cette intervention
d'aujourd'hui ceci étant il me semble
qu'il est prématuré que ça mérite un
petit peu de d'approfondissement la
suppression du terme indépendants ouvre
la possibilité à donc à tous salariés
intervenant dans le domaine des métiers
d'art de se prévaloir de la qualité
d'artisan
quel que soit potentiellement la nature
de l'activité de son entreprise
cette évolution est de nature à créer
une certaine insécurité juridique lors
de litiges opposant des artisans
indépendants et des salariés dans les
métiers concernés
dans son rapport pour avis sur le projet
de loi relatif à l'artisanat aux
commerces et aux très petites
entreprises
notre collègue didier marie était très
clair sur le fait que l'appellation
artisans ne vise non pas les individus
mais les entreprises et que l'article
1 de la loi du 5 juillet 96 ne définit
pas de manière exhaustive les métiers
d'art mais seulement les entreprises qui
au sein des artisans relève des métiers
là et pourquoi il ne nous paraît pas
souhaitable
aujourd'hui de toucher à la rédaction de
l'article 20 au risque de remettre en
cause un équilibre qui figure dans la
loi depuis 1996 c'est en ça reste un
sujet sur lequel on est tous sensibles
aux abl madame la ministre voit
peut-être j'aimerais commencer par dire
que ces métiers d'art qu'on évoque sont
une richesse extraordinaire pour la
france panique mandarom secteur culturel
pour la france en général avec des
serres on a des savoir-faire
effectivement qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs
valoriser plus est il est vrai que la
définition aujourd'hui qui est dans la
loi ne couvrent pas tous les cas où nous
avons cette excellence pour les métiers
d'art je pense notamment à des
établissements que je connais bien comme
sèvres où les gobelins en même temps on
aurait préféré du côté du gouvernement
engagé une concertation entre les
différents départements ministériels
concernés et aussi avec les
organisations professionnelles pour
peut-être arrivé à la rédaction
juridique la plus la plus pertinente
comme vous l'heureux le releviez mais
compte-tenu effectivement la pertinence
du sujet je m'en remets à la sagesse de
la de la haute assemblée en fait alors
je mets aux voix cet amendement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission et un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement qui est
pour et qui est contre
il est adopté et nous en sommes au
centre rectifié qui le présente monsieur
assouline
vous avez la parole
le secteur des arts visuels on y est
monsieur le rapporteur mais pas une
industrie culturelle il est constitué
d'une multitude d'acteurs privés publics
et surtout associatif qui maillent
l'ensemble du territoire
c'est ce qui fait sa force mais aussi sa
faiblesse
il en résulte notamment que les arts
visuels sont régulièrement les oublier
les parents pauvres de toutes les
politiques publiques
l'amendement adopté lors de l'examen en
commission culturelle va permettre aux
artistes visuels d'être rémunéré au
titre de l'exploitation de leurs oeuvres
en ligne et je m'en réjouis
il en reste néanmoins beaucoup à faire
et plus particulièrement en termes de
droits sociaux
je vous avais dit et dans mon rapport
annuel sur la création je les dis aussi
au cours des débats précédant la
situation sociale de la couverture
sociale des droits sociaux de ces
professions et lamentable pour un pays
comme la france et qui s'honore tant de
grands artistes dans ces domaines est
depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui masque aussi la
situation de la plus grande partie de
ces artistes le public a tendance à
penser que comme quelques grands noms
sont connus et qu'ils doivent vivre très
bien de leurs oeuvres et de leurs rares
cette masse qui visent souvent sous le
seuil de pauvreté est très peu regardez
et quand on regarde les sa situation
sociale elle n'est pas bonne du tout il
convient donc notamment de consolider ma
et moderniser le régime de sécurité
sociale des artistes auteurs
c'est aujourd'hui une nécessité
impérative dans la pratique le droit
commun n'est pas respectée notamment par
l'ag ça qui ne collecte pas la
cotisation vieillesse des assujettis les
photographes sont toujours tenus
d'exercer trois années d'activité pour
pouvoir bénéficier du régime de sécurité
sociale
parmi l'ensemble des déclarants en bnc
les artistes auteurs sont à la fois les
plus précaires et les seuls pénalisés
par le calcul de leurs cotisations
sociales en raison du
joe ration artificielle de leurs bnc le
15 pour cent les artistes auteurs
peuvent ainsi systématiquement des
cotisations sociales y compris celles
ghsr des sur un montant supérieur à ce
qu'ils ont réellement perçus bon je
pourrais encore énuméré
à chaque fois on m'a dit